the holiday season will certainly look  different this year several holiday  traditions here in the valley are  adapting  that includes the cactus garden at ethel  m chocolates  you're looking at video from last year  to kick off the season the lighting  ceremony will be held virtually on  november 6th  the garden will then open up to the  public the next day on saturday november  7th right through january third  reservations are required and pictures  with  santa claus will be available no matter  what you need a picture with santa with  old saint nick  i'm so glad that some traditions are  still going to continue to the holidays  pandemic aside santa claus pictures will  happen thank you for  watching eight news now at 6 30.